there there is more good news it's also
kind of bad news but we got some good
instances of bad news
i got this story here from timcast.com
san francisco crime leads to reduced
target hours not the biggest story in
the world but this is actually important
because of the massive wave of of
shoplifting yeah
target and walgreens have announced
they're going to be closing around 6 p.m
can you imagine that before dark before
you get out of work
yeah or you know so so you got to work
maybe at five you're going to make it
target in time to get your groceries
probably not but this is part of the
death spiral
the quality of life is dropping so
rapidly in san francisco so let me talk
about what this means in terms of good
news and bad news
well basically what you have in san
francisco is
praxis what they love to tweet about
they love tweeting this
these leftists these these uh you know
communists these marxists
they will show a video of antifa beating
some old person and they'll put like a
picture of a guy the meme of the guy
rubbing his face saying praxis like they
love
watching antifa just brutally beat white
people or something like that
well this is what it really looks like
san francisco crumbles
40 percent of san francisco san
francisco residents plan to leave due to
quality of life according to a poll
so here's the good news the good news is
these things don't work
and we still have a system in place
where people can flee these things and
their failures
and that will strip a lot of the power
away it was perhaps easy
in some of these places in europe and in
germany because they were smaller or
there weren't very many places to go i
mean look russia and soviet union were
very big
but the united states is very diverse in
terms of ideology
and there's always a place to rush to
because it's not sweeping from the top
down necessarily it's from the bottom up
so as san francisco implements these
failing policies
people just leave yeah now the bad news
the cities are failing which is awful
right there's crime there's homelessness
and then these people who vote in those
politicians moved to texas
where i i there was there's there's a
thread from this uh this woman
that it's actually really great it's
michelle tandler says conservative
twitter is all over this i highly
recommend reading the quote tweets
for a deeper understanding of how how
many in america view sf the left etc
this individual actually points out as a
democrat
that the cities are very much in trouble
saying you know nobody is saying we are
x percent up in this category
it's how they feel walking the streets
it's walking a stroller next to a tent
there's a pile of bikes next to it
it's being screamed at or chased by
someone who seems mentally unstable
what i'm seeing is that there is a big
enough incident it shakes people up
if there is it could be seeing a robber
try to climb through your child's
bedroom
being pulled off your bike having
someone chase you with a pipe these
incidents shake people up
and they're friends too ultimately i
think the biggest responsibility of
government is to protect people from one
another
it is the place it is it is in place to
protect us from assault theft robbery
etc
right now the criminal justice system in
sf is not working it is allowing people
to get high on very powerful drugs and
terrorize one another
neighbors stores it is allowing rampant
theft burglary car break-ins
it is allowing mentally unstable felons
to stab elderly women
what do people say in response to these
threats where are you moving to
i'm moving to texas no don't
they're gonna and they're gonna vote
more of the same in
and change texas potentially right yeah
but people are moving with their feet
right they're they're making decisions
with their feet and i think
at the ballot box like i'm confident
that this is going to impact this issue
is going to impact
gubernatorial race in virginia any races
we have this year
and then the midterm election i should
read some more of this uh she says
my whole life i've considered myself a
proud liberal progressive san francisco
democrat
today i am ashamed of my city i see smug
ignorance of the laws and of unintended
consequences
moral grandstanding winning over data
logic and facts
radical candidates winning elections
unopposed social justice warriors
getting into government and wreaking
havoc on neighborhoods businesses and
children
what why have we been asleep at the
wheel
where is our sense of civic duty civic
pride is this who we want to be
perhaps what these children are learning
will will be the shock to the system of
of the moms
maybe seeing sf become a poop
proliferator
wasn't enough i don't live in san fran i
don't care what they do
then one day their kid comes home with
this book and says mom why did you lie
to me you racist
right right why did you lie to me about
who i am and what i am
and i can't trust you and it's not just
uh typical parent-child debates or
disputes i mean this is like
essential to like the deceit
you know that's what they're basically
teaching is parents have been deceitful
i mentioned this several times in the
past week or so but but it is extremely
relevant to this that
i went to a skate park and there was
graffiti black lives matter
which was fascinating to me because the
graffiti i see growing up was very
anti-establishment
after system things like that well
what's so
comical is all you have to do being an
investigative reporter i love to look at
this thing called 990s which are the irs
filings of 501c3
organizations you look up black lives
matter
movement and they have millions of
dollars in their coffers
they've got as we know their founders
have multi-million dollar
you know homes and mansions that they're
spending on follow the money like
that's what i've had so much uh thrill
doing being a nancy drew in all these
school districts following the money
because
when you actually look at how they're
spending their money
and how they're getting wealthy off of
it they're just corporations too
yeah they are these books i would
imagine you said that state funds
are paying for these books and so these
authors are getting paid out oh
absolutely yeah um jason reynolds just
got eight thousand dollars for 45
minutes in arlington virginia on a zoom
call
wow eight thousand for a zoom co-wow
yeah but almost two hundred dollars a
minute holy cow that's the grift
that's i love it i love you when these
leftists are like uh so this is really
funny
um i got denied a home loan i've talked
about it before yeah i heard
and uh so finally i tweeted it was navy
federal right they sent me a letter in
the mail with false credit information
which i'm very
angry by and of course as it goes in
today's modern era
they will ignore you they will not you
know so i tweet about it knowing
this is how you get their attention of
course they responded immediately
and a bunch of people mentioned how they
wouldn't respond to them because they
don't have millions of followers or
whatever
but one person said tim poole is
grifting he's just trying to get people
angry at navy federal to make money or
something and i'm like what
who's got beef with maybe felt like are
we talking about but but here's here's
the point i'm trying to make not to
rehash the old story
these leftists are using grift as a
preemptive shield
to accuse their opponent that of which
they do
in an effort to say oh he's only calling
me a grifter because i called him out
for it now he's trying to deflect
right now the reality is if i wanted to
make money
why wouldn't i shill for amazon.com yeah
and walmart.com
and the massive ngos why put myself on
uh
in the out group in the resistance
fighting against the machine the machine
is safe
the machine promises you treasure in
exchange for your obedience
yeah so you know uh twitter jack
dorsey gave ibram kendy he didn't have
enough money already making twenty
thousand dollars an
hour so he got ten million dollars for
his anti-racism
center i mean that's a lot of money
right that could go
into building schools into developing
programs
and sure enough it didn't matter though
he gets his 10 million one month and the
next
next month he collected twenty thousand
dollars for an hour
is this jason reynolds guy he said he
got paid eight thousand yeah for a zoom
call was that uh state funds that he got
that was arlington county public school
money
right across the border here your tax
dollars at work your property taxes at
work
yeah and then uh the kids got his book
they got uh the 45 minutes with him
and and who paid for it though
you know who gave him the money um
amazon gave them money so we got a tip
because all of a sudden these kids were
getting these books and this mom's like
where did they get these books
so in this case we discovered that
amazon's public affairs guy
called the diversity equity inclusion
guy at
arlington public schools suburb of dc
and said
we can get you hot spots we can get you
wi-fi
and the guy said no we want this book
we want 45 minutes on zoom with this guy
so they
they picked the candy instead of kindles
just a minor correction it's diversity
inclusivity
exactly die right i love it i love it
they chose those words
yeah we got to re-brand it that's the
game they play don't fight on their
territory yeah called the die cult
i love it it is the die cult and these
guys are
killing america critical race praxis but
then we'll just call it crp but we could
just call it c-r-a
yeah there you go we'll just call it
crap critical race applied praxis
well race is r a so the a can just be in
there oh yeah
yeah right basically we got to use their
words against them and
i i it's so important that we focus on
that it's the praxis and not the theory
that's being taught
yeah they're not teaching about the
theory they're indoctrinating and making
people
behave with that theory as they study
all sorts of yeah
stuff so this is the theory right right
here this is the bible this is their
their yeah you love this this is this is
oh yeah
i love to back up chris ruffo because
who was right on joey and reed's
kimberly crenshaw is in there and then
who are you going to read from now
this is i'm going to read crenshaw yep
so she's
the mother of intersectionalism the one
who decides that
zionist feminists are not feminist
enough amazing
so i wonder if there's a little bit more
context i could read but um
i'll just read one very simple portion
it says
principally organized by kimberly
crenshaw neil gatanda and stephanie
phillips
the workshop drew together 35 law
scholars who responded to a call to
synthesize a theory
that while grounded in critical theory
was responsive to the realities of
racial politics in america
indeed the organizers coined the term
critical race theory
to make it clear that our work locates
itself in the intersection of critical
theory and race
racism and the law what does that mean
critical theory is essentially a marxist
philosophy a oppressor and oppressed
and what the the critical race theorists
were basically saying was
they didn't think marx understood the
realities of racism in america
that it was easy in this small insular
country and
um homogenous country to say it's class
it's the wealthy and the poor it's the
worker and the bourgeoisie it's the
proletariat
in the united states race plays this
role so they decided to take
that that framework and apply race to it
so it is very
much rooted in marxist critical theory
ideology etc
there's a bunch of other components to
this as well the frankfurt school that
goes on
but when when joanne reed says to chris
arufo it's not marxist
it's not true she's lying ibram candy
said
critical race theory is a huge component
of his work and anti-racism and what it
means
they're trying to hide from you what's
really going on yeah and so this book is
published 1995.
okay long before any of this trickles
down into our k-12 schools
and she had had the workshop that tim
just read about was in the 1980s
at harvard law school with derrick bell
oh in fact
yeah in fact i could be wrong i believe
the fort i read was from cornell west
oh okay all right great so uh faces at
the bottom of the well
became it's written by derek bell the
godfather of critical race theory at
harvard
yeah you want to check it out um so so
this you know this argument that they've
been putting forward
that critical race theory is not taught
in schools one that's being debunked now
it is kind of relevant okay great great
it's good to check the facts give away
that's the interest yeah
um but so it has been a long journey
you know and it is a long it has been a
long journey since the 1970s
when it was first formed in that
workshop that you read
they were the architects of it in 1980s
the book gets published in the 1990s
and now wow what do we have
notebooks and stamped workshops for kids
you know it's it's diabolical and it's
genius because it's so insidious
but but ultimately it's it's um
evil i mean it really is evil thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus
episodes thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next time
you